is there something to be said about
quantum gravity yes that's exactly the
right point to talk about
so namely we have talked about quantum
fields and i talked about electric
forces
photon being the particle carrying those
forces so for gravity
quantizing gravitational field which is
this curvature of space time according
to einstein
you get another particle called graviton
so what about gravitons should be there
no problem so then you start computing
it
what do i mean by computing it well you
compute scattering of one graviton off
another graviton maybe
graviton with an electron and so on see
what you get
feynman had already mastered the this uh
quantum electrodynamics he said no
problem let me do it
even though these are such weak forces
the gravity is very weak so therefore to
see them
these quantum effects of gravitational
waves is was impossible
it's even impossible today so feinman
just did it for fun
he usually you know had this mindset
that i want to do something which i will
see an experiment but this one let's
just see what it does
and he was surprised because the same
techniques he was using
for doing the same calculations quantum
electrodynamics when applied to gravity
failed the formula seemed to make sense
but he had to do some integrals and he
found that when he does those integrals
he got infinity
and it didn't make any sense now there
were similar infinities in the other
pieces that but he had managed to make
sense out of those before
this was no way he could make sense out
of it he just didn't know what to do
he didn't feel as an urgent issue
because nobody could do the experiment
so he was kind of said okay there's this
thing but okay we don't know how to
exactly do it but
but that's the way it is so in some
sense a natural conclusion
from what feynman did could have been
like gravity cannot be consistent with
quantum theory
but that cannot be the case because
gravity is in our universe quantum
mechanics in our universe they both
together somehow it should work
so it's not acceptable to say you know
they don't work together so
so that was a puzzle how does it
possibly work it was
left open and then we get to the string
theory so this is the puzzle of quantum
gravity the particle description of
quantum gravity fails
so the infinity shows up what do we do
what do we do with infinity
you